chesley crist has died she was 30 years
old
chris won miss usa in 2019 and was a
well-respected lawyer tv correspondent
and activist miss usa 2019
is
north carolina
et received confirmation of chris's
death from the nypd on sunday the
statement included that the nypd
responded to a 9-1-1 call and upon
arrival they found 30-year-old chesley
chris laying on the ground unconscious
and unresponsive ems arrived and
pronounced her dead on the scene the
nypd added their preliminary
investigation shows quote the woman
jumped from a high floor in the building
the circumstances surrounding her fatal
fall are still being investigated by
police chris's family released a
statement to extra where she worked as a
correspondent they shared in part quote
in devastation and great sorrow we share
the passing of our beloved chesley her
great light was one that inspired others
around the world with her beauty and
strength adding quote she cared she
loved she laughed and she shined chesley
embodied love and served others we know
her impact will live on celebrities took
to social media to share tributes
caramel wrote on twitter quote this
breaks my heart rest in peace love
garcelle beauvais said quote so sad
prayers to her family chris was an
alumni of the university of south
carolina she later graduated with a law
degree becoming an attorney following
her miss usa crowning chris used her
platform to speak out on social justice
issues in addition to being crown miss
usa you're also a lawyer right yes so i
do civil litigation and funny enough my
stepdad oh i've got a picture up here
yeah that's my stepdad who's actually
sponsoring me getting sworn in because
he's also an attorney which is really
nice and we've done a couple of pro bono
cases together which has been incredibly
exciting but yes so full-time attorney
yeah that's actually thank you
it is yes yes we've worked for some
people who have gotten some excessive
sentences and worked with people who
have been sentenced to um our one client
has been sentenced to life in prison for
a non-violent drug crime and so we've
worked a lot with him and with a few
other clients and that's really
important work to us
you